Hello.
My name is Jarrett Krosoczka, and I write and illustrate books for children for a living.
So, I use my imagination as my full-time job,...
...but well before my imagination was my vocation, my imagination saved my life.
When I was a kid, I loved to draw, and the most talented artist I knew was my mother,...
...but my mother was addicted to heroin,...
...and when your parent is a drug addict,...
...it's kind of like Charlie Brown trying to kick the football.
Because as much as you want to love on that person,...
...as much as you want to receive love from that person,...
...every time you open your heart, you end up on your back.
So, throughout my childhood, my mother was incarcerated and I didn't have my father...
...because I didn't even learn his first name until I was in the sixth grade,...
...but I had my grandparents, my maternal grandparents Joseph and Shirley,...
...who adopted me just before my third birthday and took me in as their own...
...after they had already raised five children.
So, two people who grew up in the Great Depression,...
...there in the very, very early '80s, took on a new kid.
I was the Cousin Oliver of the sitcom of the Krosoczka family,...
...the new kid who came out of nowhere,...
...and I would like to say that life was totally easy with them.
They each smoked two packs a day, each, non-filtered, and by the time I was six,...
...I could order a Southern Comfort Manhattan, dry with a twist, rocks on the side,...
...the ice on the side so you could fit more liquor in the drink.
But they loved the hell out of me.
They loved me so much,...
...and they supported my creative efforts because my grandfather was a self-made man.
He ran and worked in a factory.
My grandmother was a homemaker.
But here was this kid who loved Transformers and Snoopy and the Ninja Turtles,...
...and the characters that I read about, I fell in love with, and they became my friends.
So, my best friends in life were the characters I read about in books.
I went to Gates Lane Elementary School in Worcester, Massachusetts,...
...and I had some wonderful teachers there, most notably in first grade, Mrs. Alisch,...
...and I just, I can just remember the love that she offered us as her students.
When I was in the third grade, a monumental event happened.
An author visited our school, Jack Gantos.
A published author of books came to talk to us about what he did for a living.
And afterwards, we all went back to our classrooms...
...and we drew our own renditions of his main character, Rotten Ralph.